This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I think if you ask somebody on the street, what is camouflage? I believe the most common answer would be to say, well, it's a figure and it's being hidden by being blended with its background. Scientists today call that background matching. I call that high similarity camouflage. That's Roy Barons. I'm Roy Barons, and I teach in the Department of Art at the University of Northern Iowa.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马斯。我想如果你在街上问某个人，什么是迷彩？我相信最常见的回答会是，嗯，它是一个图形，通过与背景融为一体而被隐藏起来。今天的科学家称之为背景匹配。我称之为高相似度迷彩。那是罗伊·巴伦斯。我是罗伊·巴伦斯，我在北爱荷华大学艺术系教书。
I teach graphic design and the history of design. Barons is also one of the foremost camouflage experts. Well, I wouldn't go that far. I would. I do. High similarity or blending is just one type of camouflage. It's kind of the boring one. But another type of camouflage that you can find both in nature and in military use is
我教平面设计和设计史。巴伦斯也是最重要的迷彩专家之一。嗯，我不会走得那么远。我会的。我会的。高相似度或融合只是迷彩的一种。这可以说是比较枯燥的一种。但你可以在自然界和军事应用中找到的另一种迷彩是
disruptive camouflage. I call it figure disruption. Figure disruption. Think because it breaks up the figure, it's the opposite of high similarity camouflage. It's high difference. So you're making it very difficult for us to look at the figure and to see it as only a single continuous thing. Rubption? Thru-figure-thruption? Dis- Dis- Zebra stripes have long been thought to be a form of disruptive camouflage.
破坏性迷彩。我称之为图形破坏。图形破坏。我想因为它打破了图形，这是高相似度迷彩的对立面。它是高差异的。所以你让人们很难看着这个图形，并把它看作是一个单一的连续事物。破坏？通过-图形-破坏？分-分-斑马条纹长期以来一直被认为是破坏性迷彩的一种形式。
The stripes make it hard for a predator to distinguish one zebra from another when the zebras are in a large herd. The stripes might also make zebra's less attractive to blood-sucking horseflies. But when it comes to humans, the greatest, most jaw-droppingly spectacular application of disruptive camouflage by the military is Razzle Dazzle. Dazzle camouflage strictly applies to ship camouflage, and even more strictly, it applies to World War I ship camouflage. And it came about because it was discovered that it's almost impossible to make a ship invisible on the ocean. The horizon is changing in color, it's changing in amount of light, so there are all kinds of
这些条纹使捕食者在斑马处于庞大族群时很难区分一头斑马和另一头斑马。条纹还可能使斑马对吸血的虻类吸引力降低。但当谈到人类时，军队对破坏性迷彩最伟大、最令人惊叹的壮观应用是“炫目迷彩”。炫目迷彩严格适用于舰船迷彩，更严格地说，它适用于第一次世界大战的舰船迷彩。它的出现是因为人们发现，要在海洋中让一艘船隐形几乎是不可能的。地平线在变色，光线在变强变弱，所以有各种各样的
conditions that make it so a constantly moving ship can't blend into the background of the sea. And even if you could make a ship invisible, you still have smoke coming out of the sea. And even if you could make a ship invisible, you still have smoke coming out of the smoke stack, so it's not as if you're hiding the ship at all. So the less heavily armor ships were sitting ducks. The crisis came about at the time that the US had not yet entered the war. Remember, this is World War I. It was the British ships that were being sunk, and the German submarines were sinking as many as 50 ships a week. Many of those ships were merchant ships and they were bringing supplies to England,
条件使得一艘不断移动的船无法融入大海的背景中。而且即使你能让一艘船隐形，你仍然会有烟雾从海面上冒出来。即使你能让一艘船隐形，你仍然会有烟雾从烟囱里冒出来，所以这并不意味着你把船藏起来了。因此，防护较弱的船只成了活靶子。危机出现在美国尚未参战的时候。记住，这是第一次世界大战。被击沉的是英国船只，德国潜水艇每周击沉多达50艘船。其中许多船是商船，它们向英国运送物资，
which is an island, of course, and it really depended on those. And then also there was armaments and other things that were being secretly taken there too. So the design solution was not about invisibility. It was about disruption. A number of artists decided that the best way to avoid getting torpedoed was not to make the ship invisible, but to make it hard to hit.
英国当然是一个岛屿，它非常依赖这些物资。然后还有武器和其他被秘密运往那里的东西。因此，设计方案不是关于隐形。它是关于破坏。许多艺术家认为，避免被鱼雷击中的最好方法不是让船隐形，而是让它很难被击中。
That's why these kind of erratic, crazy quilt patterns came about, and that's why they were used in that war. It's going to be hard to picture this, but I wanted to try. That once was a time when military ships, even US ships by this point were painted with, and I quote, This is from an anonymous article in New York Times from 1918. Any New Yorker will see at anchor or coming in or going out numerous ships whose painted signs reveal such wild extravagances of form and color as make the landsmen open his eyes with amazement and mystification.
这就是为什么会出现这种不规律、疯狂的百衲被图案，也是为什么它们在那场战争中被使用的原因。这很难想象，但我还是想试一试。曾几何时，军舰，甚至到这个时候连美国船只都涂上了——我引述一下，这是1918年《纽约时报》上一篇匿名文章的内容。任何纽约人在锚地、进港或出港时都会看到无数的船只，它们涂装的标志展现出形式和色彩的狂野奢华，让乡下人惊奇和迷惑地睁大了眼睛。
Black and white was very common. They consist of stripes and swirls and kind of arabesque, almost art nouveau shapes. Blue was very common. They consist of stripes and swirls and kind of arabesque, almost art nouveau shapes. Blue was used predominantly, especially in the British versions. But I think you'd be surprised at the range of colors. There were reds that were sometimes used in greens and really quite intense oranges.
黑白两色非常普遍。它们由条纹、漩涡和类似藤蔓、几乎是新艺术运动风格的形状组成。蓝色被广泛使用，特别是在英国版本中。但我认为你会对色彩的范围感到惊讶。有时会使用红色、绿色和非常浓烈的橙色。
Another unidentified US journalist wrote, you should see our fleet. It's camouflage, so it looks like a flock of seagulling Easter eggs. During World War I, dazzle ship camouflage was absolutely fascinating to the public. You have to remember that this is happening just a few years after the, what's called the Armory Show in New York.
另一个未署名的美国记者写道，你应该看看我们的舰队。它经过伪装，看起来像一群海鸥复活节彩蛋。在第一次世界大战期间，炫目舰船迷彩对公众来说绝对具有吸引力。你必须记住，这发生在纽约所谓的军械库展之后仅仅几年。
It's the first international show of modern art in this country, and it was the introductory show of cubism, futurism, all of those things that people made fun of, and they thought that these are really crazy directions for artists to be going in, so that when this happened, people looked at those gypsum, they said, oh, it's a cubist nightmare, it's futurist, they've taken over the world. As you can probably guess, there were plenty of people who hated dazzle camouflage, traditional Navy men mostly.
这是这个国家第一个现代艺术国际展，也是立体主义、未来主义以及所有那些被人们取笑的事情的介绍展，他们认为这些是艺术家们非常疯狂的发展方向，所以当这件事发生时，人们看着那些石膏，哦，这是一个立体主义的噩梦，它是未来主义的，它们已经接管了世界。正如你所能猜到的，有很多人讨厌炫目迷彩，主要是传统的海军军官。
They compared it to the clothing at a prostitute would wear, and they made fun of it. Here's how it worked. I can lead you through the steps. At the time, torpedoes fired from U-boats were quite slow, maybe taking a couple minutes to reach their target. So the person firing the torpedo had to lead the target. He had to anticipate where the target ship was going to be when the torpedo arrived. So he had to calculate how to do that,
他们将其比作妓女穿的衣服，并取笑它。它是这样运作的。我可以带你了解这些步骤。当时，从U型潜艇发射的鱼雷相当慢，可能需要几分钟才能到达目标。因此，发射鱼雷的人必须预判目标。他必须预测当鱼雷到达时目标船只将在哪里。所以他必须计算如何做到这一点，
and that very much depended on knowing the exact angle it's headed toward. That's terribly terribly important. And the other thing is that you have to figure out the speed of the ship. Because then you'll know how far it can go by the time the torpedo gets there. The dazzle camouflage certainly made the ship stand out, but the bulging shapes and vivid hues also made it difficult to determine the speed and direction of the moving ship. It's praying on our assumptions about things
这非常非常取决于知道它前进的确切角度。这非常非常重要。另一件事是你必须算出船的速度。因为那样你就会知道在鱼雷到达时它能走多远。炫目迷彩确实让这艘船脱颖而出，但突出的形状和生动的色调也使得确定移动船只的速度和方向变得困难。它利用了我们的假设，即物体
looking smaller as they are more distant. So you could paint a perspective patterns on a ship that would make it look like it was turning in a different direction when in fact you're actually seeing them frontly and they're absolutely flat. The dazzle patterns broke up the figure so that it could look shorter than it really was or it could make it hard to tell if there was one ship or multiple ships. They even painted fake bow waves on them and they would paint the fake bow wave either on the front to make it look like the ship was going faster than it was actually going.
随着距离的增加而显得更小。所以你可以在一艘船上画上透视图案，让它看起来好像在向不同的方向转动，而实际上你看到的是正面，它们绝对是平坦的。炫目图案打破了图形，使其看起来比实际更短，或者很难分辨是一艘船还是多艘船。他们甚至在上面画了假的船头浪，他们会在前面画假的船头浪，让船看起来比实际速度更快。
Because that was one way of calculating that. Or they would paint the bow wave on the back. And so you would glance at it while you're looking through this periscope. You might conclude that, oh, it's going in that direction, not in the other direction. So then you surface again to calculate where you're going to shoot, and the thing is gone. It's an entirely different direction and location than you imagined. These patterns weren't just slapped on the side of giant ships
因为那是计算方法之一。或者他们会在后面画船头浪。所以当你透过潜望镜看它时，你可能会瞥一眼。你可能会得出结论，哦，它正朝着那个方向走，而不是另一个方向。所以当你再次浮出水面来计算你要射击的地方时，目标已经消失了。它是一个与你想象的完全不同的方向和位置。这些图案不仅仅是拍在巨型船只的侧面
hoping that they'd be confusing enough to be effective. Camouflures, and that's what they were called, the Camouflures, and that's what they were called, the Camouflors tested toy models by inviting an experienced submarine captains to peer through periscopes and report what angle they thought the models were appointed. They determined that sometimes on really effectively camouflage ships, the calculation of the ship captains could be off as much as 55 degrees.
希望它们足够混乱以发挥作用。迷彩设计者——他们就是这么被称呼的，迷彩设计者——通过邀请经验丰富的潜水艇长透过潜望镜窥视并报告他们认为模型指向什么角度来测试玩具模型。他们确定，有时在真正有效的迷彩船只上，船长的计算可能会偏差达55度。
Dazzle only had to screw up the torpedo gunners estimate by 8 degrees for the target ship to effectively avoid a torpedo. The theater of war has changed, so camouflage has changed with it, but there is still dazzle to be found. Actually, if you look at military craft today, there is still dazzle being practiced. But of course, the conditions have changed. Just as in World War I, this came out of those particular set of conditions.
炫目只需将鱼雷炮手的估算搞砸8度，目标船只就能有效地躲避鱼雷。战争的剧场已经改变，所以迷彩也随之改变，但仍然可以找到炫目。事实上，如果你看看今天的军用船只，仍然有人在实践炫目。但当然，条件已经变了。正如在第一次世界大战中一样，这是从特定的一套条件中产生的。
We have to say, well, those are the conditions that we have now, so what would be most effective today? If you look at aircraft, it's broken up very often. If you look at ships, some of them are broken up through these geometric patterns. If you look at some camouflage uniforms, infantry uniforms around the world, you'll find all kinds of break up with dazzle and so forth, are tanks or trucks or so forth. But I'm sad to report that there are no longer flocks of sea-going Easter eggs. 99% Invisible is produced by me Roman Mars and Sam Greenspan. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco. In the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco.
我们不得不说，嗯，这些是我们现在拥有的条件，那么今天什么会最有效？如果你看飞机，它经常被分割。如果你看船只，其中一些是通过这些几何图案被分割的。如果你看看世界各地的迷彩制服，步兵制服，你会发现各种各样的带有炫目效果的分割等等，坦克或卡车等等。但我难过地报告说，再也没有成群的远洋复活节彩蛋了。《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马斯和萨姆·格林斯潘制作。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目。以及旧金山美国建筑师学会。
You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars, but this week you absolutely must go to 99%imvisible.org and look at pictures of dazzle ships. They are just that amazing. You will not believe it. All you will do this week is talk about dazzle ships, I almost guarantee it. 99%imvisible.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞，我在罗曼·马斯那里发推文，但本周你绝对必须去99%invisible.org看炫目船只的照片。它们就是那么神奇。你不会相信的。这周你所做的全部事情就是谈论炫目船只，我几乎可以保证。99%invisible.org。广播电台来自PRX。这个没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。